justin trudeau it was on Patriot Act
with Hasan Minhaj and Hasan did not let
up on the Prime Minister what do you
think of Trudeau being on the Netflix
show finish the sentence Tim Hortons is
a Canadian institution nice finish the
sentence Kawhi Leonard should should be
very proud of what he accomplished in
his time in Canada I completely disagree
Kawhi Leonard should never return to
Canada because he is a traitor that's
the correct answer
you know people bring American
sentiments on to Canadian politeness
every now and then finish the sentence
and Canada will not sell any more
weapons to Saudi Arabia period sorry mr.
Canada will not sell any more weapons to
Saudi Arabia please that's a good
statement you said nine months ago you
guys would be examining and yeah it
takes about three months to study for
the LSAT so that's a pretty good
examination time you could you could
announce it right here right now we
can't swing the deal we take that all
right here wild on can you take our
legal responsibilities and the breaking
of contracts very seriously in this
country okay one of the big topics they
got into is climate change and the XL
pipeline that cheveux has approved a
sign question why someone who is so
focused on climate change would approve
the pipeline you guys are this society
that has cracked so many things that we
are struggling with health care
immigration what else
lots of things the integration and
multiculturalism in a way that keeps
vibrant difference exactly you guys are
this amazing progressive country that's
almost like the civilization from the
future you guys are like will Condon you
guys look like real Canada except we're
not covered by a real protective bubble
that nobody can see so - the bubble I'm
in what Canada I'm speaking to the
leader of all Canada the son of the
former leader of all Canada
which makes you the Prime Minister of
Canada because we had you're a white man
there I'm like 160 in Malaysia sir
enough to decide we don't have to get in
the Elizabeth Warren math you are white
Panther fans around the world are
looking to white panther and what Canada
and can you imagine if we found out that
this precious resource vibranium is
causing climate change and white panther
is like what we're not gonna just leave
hundreds of millions of dollars of
vibranium in the ground mm-hmm I would
be like T'Challa
know at the screen no you'd be you'd be
in a movie if you were doing that pachow
this is a really interesting interview
if they cover a lot of stuff like I know
people are gonna say well why is he
doing this you know frivolous show they
did get into all those I don't think it
shows frivolous at all I think people
are gonna you know white you know the
Hollywood you know side that people
always say but just in general that he's
as too much of this kind of stuff but
you cover all the major issues anyway
Christine this is one a tool a pulse is
love it good on Justin for to take the
punches and on both sides of that I mean
it's got to be intimidating for a ass
and go into that but not only does it
want to do a great interview he also Stu
comedy at the same time like I find
these guys so impressive that pull this
up because there's so low reaches and so
will prepare but you have to be fun at
the same time and even with Justin I
mean he knows these guys they know their
stuff and they know they're gonna come
at them and they know they're quick
they're very quick-witted so you gotta
be prepared so kudos adjustment for
doing that kind of interview cuz yeah
yet put in a tough spot a little bit
it doesn't make you look great no that's
the thing that it's because I think that
Justin had a lot of that when he when he
came out I think he had a lot of no
matter where he sat down people were
going to be fawning you know all all
over him and looks had so much to do
with it right you know they were making
cardboard cutouts of them but if justin
trudeau
you know looked like Rob Ford I don't
think that they would have cardboard
cutout so and like his his sort of
dashing you know qualities were such a
huge part of his brand when when he
started that moments like this I think
like it probably hurts
little bit because people are now
talking record and talking promises and
talking policy which is what they should
have been doing at the beginning and
nobody did and so that's why Justin
Trudeau looks uncomfortable because
these are situations that he's not used
to right because his people don't put
him in situations like this in Canada
but it's a huge Netflix show and you
take the chance you're like you know get
that Netflix audience right you know
maybe it's good if he gives you one
point bump you know is it worth it but
it also could be a colossal disaster I
don't think it was a colossal disaster
no I just don't think that he came he
was as charming as he would have liked
to have been curious is I can't tell if
Justin was acting or he really could
just barely tolerate his Ann but I was
over at Trudeau here in the states I
loved the interview but his in isn't
wrong and he said did show both sides of
you know what the Liberals point is what
the Conservatives stance is so yeah
you're just trying to present the issue
that's going on to Canada for those
people that aren't aware of Canadian
politics yeah make your own decision
based on yeah but you it's it's one of
those shows where you take a gamble you
know you take a Reno Bernie Sanders went
on Joe Rogan right you know I'm sure
people were like don't go on Joe Rogan
that's a lot of heat you don't want that
heat on you but you take that chance
look it's a massive audience and you
just hope that you're gonna be able to
get your point across in a way that is
not a 30-second sound bite and hopefully
maybe somebody comes across to yourself
Lois's Justin - looked uncomfortable
from time to time but it was a great at
funding yeah yeah